i'm the one of the biggest conan fans
i would say ever and uh he's just
he's the reason i do stand up and doing
his show
was just like it was a little scary
because it's like after this
what is there to live for you know like
when you have these dreams
i have a little bit of that with conan
you know it's only gotten better and our
i've become like friends with him but um
there are these moments where you get to
meet the people that you've always
wanted to meet and then you're like okay
well i don't really
have any more goals in life it was like
conan dave matthews and i guess
jennifer anston i still have to meet her
and then i can um then i can die
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome the
very funny
nikki glazer you have a great anderson
impression
which is just
okay yeah yeah i do
oh god jp
yeah i do like it's just you just have
to act like you're watching a squirrel
almost get hit by a car that's the s i
always go into anderson whenever i'm
like oh
oh oh no no no oh oh oh
oh god oh like that's always my
that's where i go too for that
i found a couple of photos also uh of
you
backstage before the show oh i'm just
curious
let me know if this brings any sort of
sense memory oh my gosh
yes oh this is the best because there's
always whenever i do it even
whether i'm doing panel or when i did
stand up
these guys that whole open the curtains
for you are so nice
everyone backstage and everyone at conan
is just
so kind and friendly and i always just
feel like god i want to work it's just
fun it's it's a fun day for me and
everyone's always excited i'm there it
just
it always feels like my birthday when
i'm there so i just remember talking to
these two guys and feeling
and just having some chit chat that eat
that really calm my nerves
but um right now in this moment i'm
i don't think i'm obviously i'm nervous
look at me i'm like gripping that very
hard and my outfit is like i remember
getting fitted for this and i was at the
time i was doing
an mtv show where they dressed me like a
barbie doll so this was still like kind
of in that realm of
uh dressing like uh i was gonna be on
mtv very soon
and um yeah but i was like very at this
point i'm probably going over my jokes
i'm looking down so i'm thinking about
my jokes thinking about the order making
sure
i get it all right and while also trying
to have a conversation with these two
sweet gentlemen
this is backstage still this is
backstage
whoever is backstage and be like i like
your shoes like i like to have some kind
of moment that grounds me
and makes me feel like myself because i
want to go out there
and talk the same way that i talk
you know backstage so i like to just be
like
oh my god wait what is that or like just
have some sort of interaction so i think
i'm always dying to like pose for a
picture and be like
you got it like just get me out of my
head for a second
so that's i do this every time at your
show
please welcome the very funny nikki
[Applause]
glazer
hello how are you
me too me too i flew here a couple days
ago from new york city uh whenever i fly
my mom always gets so nervous
she's like will you call me when you
land so i know you got in safely
i'm like how about i don't call you and
you just watch the news later
i love this joke more than you did
i'll admit yeah i will openly admit that
this was me pushing you to do this joke
i love this joke jp but i know i knew
this joke and i
knew that it never gets what it deserves
and
it makes me so mad even watching it now
first of all i'm nervous as hell i'm
holding the mic weird i always hold my
mic way too high
i'm nervous so that wasn't helping the
joke but this joke never does well
and it make this is one of the jokes
that i'm gonna bring back and work on
because this deserves more than it got
and it always
doesn't get as much as it deserves so
you're not wrong and i'm so glad you
believed in it
your first joke never gets what it
should because they're hearing your
voice
they're getting used to you and the fact
even though you did say hello nice to be
here you did just start cold
having another sacrificial lamb ahead of
this joke would have helped
the secret to stand up is not really
being funny
it's making the audience comfortable and
know that you've
you've got this and you've they can eat
sit back and relax watching someone
who's nervous
whether or not they're hilarious is your
you'll bomb so you can be very unfunny
and just look comfortable and people
laugh that's just like a trick
but uh this joke i'm nervous
it requires too much of a leap in logic
and it's too much for the first joke but
i don't regret it i'm glad we got it out
of the way
and i'm excited to bring it back another
option for an opener that
you had just you like you were recently
you're a bad driver and you were dry you
were out and you had
hit a deer dear old man and i hope he's
okay i left a note
yeah yeah that that showed actually
anthony jeselnik had a sim the sa is
that pretty much the same joke that he
later put in a special
and so i wasn't ever able to do that
again but
that joke that joke would have been
perfect i mean my
my favorite opener the one that always
works and that i use all the time is i
just i'm nikki i just turned um
i just turned 27 in june of 2008 or
whatever you know like what
that one always gets them to just the
shortest amount of time between you
saying
starting your first joke and the laugh
is the best opener
i have a roommate in new york she's not
there much anymore because she just got
a boyfriend
you know or she's like super missing but
i'm gonna hope for the best on that one
uh her parents keep calling they're like
have you seen her i'm like check
craigslist that's where i found her so
trying to help
i'd put up missing posters but she told
me not to use her printer without asking
so
my hands are tied you know just like
hers
[Music]
she's okay oh man
if i'm gonna be honest sure i i was
watching a lot of amy schumer around
this time
and like i am just it's it's so hard for
me i've had to stop watching people i
really like
because i will just sound like them and
amy was we were hanging out a lot at
this time and like that
was a total amy delivery she's one of my
favorite comedians of all time so it
makes sense
but i just watched it and i go oh like
you haven't found
like obviously i've found my style and
the the tone of the jokes but i just go
oh
she likes schumer a lot and has been
watching a lot of hers
and um i was always like really dark
with my jokes like
the fact that this girl's missing and
tied up somewhere i would change it a
lot though like now
like uh my hands are tied like hers
probably are like i wouldn't say like
hers are i would have said like hers
probably are
that would get harder because i don't
know where she is
um and then i probably would have kept
going with it like
uh it's it's funny to see now how it i
would approach these but this is this is
fun i'm actually looking at this like
she's
a different per she's not me it's making
it easier for me to watch
i had to move out when my mom found my
vibrator
i had the same reaction i did when she
found cigarettes in my purse when i was
16.
i was like mom it's not mine i'm holding
to it for a friend she had the same
reaction too though because she made me
use it until i got
sick so i learned
i learned my lesson yeah thank you
it makes me so mad that that got an
applause great because i did not write
that tag
i did write the first part because it
was all true of me saying i'm keeping it
for a friend and that's also
what i used to say when she found pot um
the joke of she made me use it until i
got sick
was written actually by my friend harris
whittles
who is now past so it's actually like a
beautiful thing that this
lives he like for me lives on in this
joke and every time i
ever like tell this joke on stage
sometimes i just remember at the middle
of my show
um i always think of him but it
there's nothing more infuriating than
when someone gives you a line and then
it's like
it's the first applause you get and
you're like oh i can't even take credit
for that but that was
that was a harris whittles it is so good
that makes me so happy i never knew that
and that
all the people that could have written
that for you that makes me the happiest
at all no
right i love it so much he lives on with
that disgusting joke
he was one of the comics who i never got
to have on the show
that i really feel disappointed that it
never happened and the fact just to hear
that
he did get a tag he got a tag a great
tag that got an applause break
i mean he he was such a great writer and
comic like
that's why he was so beloved by so many
people yeah exactly he was so
original and so cutting and so funny
and had that ability to be adorable
while saying something
heinous you were shielding your eyes and
putting your head down for most of that
but i don't know if you noticed that you
did look over
to conan that's what i like was like
okay i got this and that is crazy that i
didn't just
that's a closer joke i mean first of all
it's so gross
um you don't drop that a minute 45 in
but you know i don't play by the rules
jp
how am i gonna end this
[Music]
and the first guy was not special you
know he was just the first guy to have
like a really good argument for why we
should
you know because i was like i don't
think i'm ready and he was like come on
thank you guys very much okay okay all
right
so a great joke delivery
a lot of things i would have done
differently i'm happy with this set
definitely like started the conversation
with co
like it was a great way to first meet
conan now i want to see do you have when
conan came over oh yeah oh yeah yes
this is
that was great thank you that's
hilarious that's fantastic
nikki glazer really funny we'll take a
break we'll be right back
oh my god i was like okay so
he was so nice i mean like you could
tell like it was great like he was very
he knew that i was nervous and he was
very encouraging and it was it was great
but it wasn't
like the way you know uh
and i remember right after that i was
like i just
you are the reason i do comedy
and and i said and i'm and that is i'm
not just saying that you
are the reason i do comment he said
girls telling me that i'm the reason
they do comedy is why i do comedy or
like girls
like you talking to me is the reason i
do he said something funny like that
that was like god damn he's so hilarious
and so
nice and um and then he like took
pictures with me backstage and i uh
i definitely like cried and there's one
picture where it looks like i'm like
going to prom with him i'm like
next to him just like like i look
like uh it was just that was the best
and i was done too you know like that
when you're
when you go thank you good night and you
feel good about it it's just like that
sense of relief is
is amazing and um yeah and then i went
over and i think adam scott was on the
show he was very nice and andy of course
is always like so cool
and uh yeah that was that was great
look at the two of you chatting it up
oh i am like just trying to be
in that moment and be so cool and have
like
uh just a connection i mean that i'm
losing my mind in that photo i remember
that so much and it's i still
don't really um i'm not like it's so
hard for me to be present when i'm
talking to him because it's
it's it's just he's he's my fave but um
i remember sitting on that couch and
just feeling and i've watched
so many times and just being like i i
made it i did it
i did it and this is this was the goal
and you know i mean my friends
from high school could not believe i was
on conan because in
high school i was filling out
notebooks drawing pictures of him uh
reciting bits i'd seen the night before
highlighting in in the year 2000 the
best jokes in there
and studying the jokes i mean i was such
a huge fan so this is like
i'm again i'm trying to be cool here but
i'm not
and um and yeah i just remember getting
to sit on that couch was such a
such an honor thankfully through doing
your show like i i have found my voice
like i
i really think you know my appearances
on conan have been
are the things that pop up on youtube
that people binge and and write me about
constantly so and it's where i feel my
most self and it's where i'm the most
excited and
just uh i'm in heaven so it's
it's really cool to revisit this i am so
grateful for you
to have had me on the show um
and yeah i really i i
after that performance i was like okay i
can just i can quit now like i really
don't have any goals hosting snl is my
last real like actual entertainment goal
and even that i'm like it wasn't as
important to me as having been on conan
but
i that was like the number one goal and
i achieved it so i'm done